[Musique]
nougablons brun berlingot bariolé
pastille patte de fruits praline rose
blanche le conservatoire de la
confiserie un univers sucré et coloré
avant de déguster ces friandises retour
au 19e siècle l'âge d'or de la
confiserie turbine adragés presse à
calisson appareil à couper le caramel
mou des machines de l’air industriel
presque toutes en état de fonctionner ce
lieu unique a été imaginé par le tout
rangeau Nicolas violet fils et
petit-fils de confiseur forain bonjour
Nicolas bonjour Julien vous avez 2000
pièces dans votre collection seulement
un tiers sont présentés ici pourquoi
collectionner des pièces qui vont
jusqu'à plusieurs tonnes alors le but
c'est de préserver donc ce patrimoine
matériel et maternel de la confiserie
parce que malheureusement les confuseurs
c'est une corporation assez fermée s'ils
ont pas de succession en hydropreneur et
ferraille littéralement donc le matériel
et partent avec le serveur fin donc
petit à petit on a ce patrimoine qui
disparaît j'ai voulu par ma modeste
contribution sauvegarder de cet outil de
travail et ce savoir-faire alors ceci ce
n'est pas simplement amusé le public
peut aussi assister à la fabrication de
bonbons qu'avez-vous prévu aujourd'hui
alors aujourd'hui c'est une fabrication
de pastille les quartiers d'agrumes les
bonbons de notre enfance et après il y a
une fabrication de sucettes sur le thème
d'halloween ça marche là aujourd'hui il
y a 18 kg de sucre il a été cuit entre
135 et 140 vous voyez j'ai bien mélanger
et on a une jolie couleur orange qui est
arrivée naturellement dans l'atelier se
dégage des odeurs d'agrumes le sucre se
travaille se transforme en pâte le sucre
bien changé de texture il se tient
beaucoup plus si s'étale beaucoup moins
donc on va pouvoir le mettre sur la
machine qui est juste derrière vers vous
c'est ce qu'on appelle une roueuse cette
machine de 1910 est la plus ancienne
encore en fonctionnement elle maintient
le sucre à température le temps
d'imprimer la pâte à bonbons en quartier
d'agrumes une friandise qui rappelle
l'enfant en fait pour vous expliquer au
sein du Conservatoire en mesure de
fabriquer toutes les confiseries de
France le but c'est pas de s'accaparer
des spécialités mais sauvegarder
savoir-faire donc là ici on fabrique du
nougat alors ça correspond au nougat de
Montélimar on respecte que pourcentage
de miel mais on pourra jamais l'appeler
nous gagne montélima ou après on a donc
les pralines de Montargis on a donc les
Cotignacs de d'Orléans et ce
savoir-faire comment on l'apprend est-ce
qu'il y a des écoles spécialisées en
France en France il y a plus de
formation il y a le CAP chocolatier
confuseur mais les deux confiseurs que
de nom en fin de compte on n'apprend pas
les différents métiers de la confuserie
la seule école référente doit ce domaine
est en Allemagne donc petit à petit on
perd ce savoir-faire et c'est ça ce qui
est triste
la France exporte pourtant un tiers de
ces productions d'après le syndicat
national de la confiserie Nicolas violet
espère sauvegarder le savoir-faire
tricolore avec pourquoi pas la création
d'une école spécialisée en Touraine